and now we come to the awards for art
direction my favorite baby doll miss
Carol Baker will give Oscar to the
winners and mr. Richard Chamber will
give a pint of blood to the losers
will you assist their speaker Oh
ready dr. Callaghan Calgary art
direction black and white nominees one
the absent-minded professor art
direction by Carroll Park set decoration
by Emile Corey and Hal gozman to the
Children's Hour art direction by
Fernando career set direction by Edward
G Boyle three The Hustler art direction
by Harry Warner set decoration by Jean
Callahan for judgment at Nuremburg art
direction by Rudolf stunad set
decoration by George Milan five the
dolce vita art direction by Piero
Girardi envelope envelope
and the winner is
Harry Mona for the hustler
exceptin for poker Horner and Dean
Callaghan mr. William Fatima
on behalf of haryana a Hollywood man in
Toronto tonight working on a set for
Seattle World's Fair thank you
well you handle that very well Karen are
you ever gonna nurse no but I watch been
chasing every week
great the child is sick well we'd better
hurry on to the award for art direction
for a color picture nominees are
breakfast at tiffany's art direction by
Hal Ferrer and Roland
Anderson set decoration by Sam comer and
Ray Moyer
El Cid art direction by venereal Cola
Sante and John Moore Flower Drum Song
art direction by a like Alexander
galitsin and Joseph runt set decoration
by Howard Bristol summer and smoke art
direction by Hal Pereira and Walter
Tyler set decoration by Sam comer and
author crams West Side Story art
direction by Boris Levin set decoration
by Victor gangling under win apparel and
the winner is
Boris Levin for West Side Story
thank you very much and deeply grateful
for this honor
I am deeply grateful to the Bob wise and
the Mary's company thank you